(grooving music)
- [Voiceover] I've definitely
never dyed my hair before.
To be honest, it kinda scares me.
- [Voiceover] Guys in my culture
don't usually dye their hair.
- [Voiceover] I think that's
exactly it, being a guy.
- [Voiceover] It goes with
a little bit of a stigma.
- [Voiceover] What I'm most nervous about
is how I'm gonna feel after I have it on.
- When I see somebody
change their hair color,
that person had balls.
It's been a little difficult to get men
to change their hair.
A lot of guys like regiment.
- Usually I'm like more the
boring one of the group.
I'm not the person to do
something this drastic.
- [David] It's the quickest
way to change yourself.
- I'm excited that it's
really gonna give me some
more confidence, something
that I lack a little bit of.
- Especially Gen X, Y, now
men are actually choosing
their own hairstyles.
- I think social media has a big impact.
I saw some guys with cool
hair and I'm like, hey,
I can probably do that.
- When they really rock it out,
they start to see things
change in their lives.
- I'm most looking forward to
see myself in the mirror and
it not be what I've been seeing
for the past 20, so years.
- Each one of them have
extreme different looks
that they've chosen for themselves.
I'm excited to take them
to their elevated look.
- [Edward] I'm gonna go darker.
- With men, I don't necessarily
see them go dark that often
and the only reason why they're going dark
is because it's emotional.
- Because I'm blonde,
people sometimes look at me
and they have a preconceived notion
as to what my personality's like.
I kinda have to work to have people
take me serious sometimes.
- When you are looking at
somebody with dark hair
and with light eyes, it's mesmerizing.
- I think something that
can happen in the course
of a single day
(snaps)
and it doesn't take discipline
and time to see the results.
I think it's really gonna help me.
- From light to dark you're
putting on a single color,
but when you're going blonder,
it's completely a different process.
- I wanna go blonde today
because I think that's
a color that I could rock.
- When you're going to
that platinum blonde
you're gonna have a lot of fun.
- I come from a Haitian background
and that is totally unacceptable.
You're supposed to be very
professional at all times,
so my mom would probably cut my head off.
- When a man's walking down the street,
dark skin, light hair,
they are a lot of people that are looking
because you're like, dang,
he exudes confidence.
- I can't wait to take
some pictures with it.
Naughty pictures. (laughter)
- If one guys in the
group of guys has changed
their hair color, it starts
to become infectious.
- I've seen a lot of guys
with purple hair lately
and I think it looks pretty badass.
- There used to be this
you're blonde or you're brown.
But now, with men being
able to look outside the box
and this recent explosion
of rainbow-ized hair,
guys are like screw it, I'm creative.
- Purple's one of my favorite colors.
Purple loves me and I think
purple looks good on me.
- [David] I feel with
this wide range of color
it's definitely taking our next
generation to another level.
- [Luis] Since I'm gonna do it,
I might as well just go big.
- People are exercising
their creative space
and with hair.
- I really wanna try silver hair.
I've always wanted to look
like a video game character.
- The acceptance of gray
hair, it's boosting confidence
because now they're not
explaining why they're prematurely
graying, they're just
like, oh, it's really in.
- I'm most nervous about men. (laughter)
So many things.
What people will say
when (chuckles) they see
and Asian guy walking
around with white hair.
- From darkest Asian
haircolor, and it's coarse,
and there's a lot of dimension to it.
You're lightening, you're discoloring,
you're seeing where this hair's
going, you're pretty much
gonna have to plan your
whole day around it.
And I've seen so many times
that I've spun the chair around
and they get a shot of
themselves in the mirror
and it's like woah.
(bouncing music)
Three, two, one.
(laughter)
- Oh, wow.
- Doesn't it look great?
Who is that?
- Oh yeah, that's crazy.
- Hello!
Are you there?
- That is wild.
- [David] This is just a really,
really great color for you,
so a lot of people are gonna think, wait,
is that your natural hair?
- [Edward] I love it.
- Who do you think is gonna react the best
to you, right now?
- I don't know, maybe myself. (chuckles)
(laughter)
(delighted laughter)
(surprised laughter)
- What do you think?
- [Richardson] This is like, crazy.
My hair is like another color.
I'm getting used to it, I really like it.
- Do you still feel boring?
- I definitely do not feel boring.
(laughter)
- Where am I?
Oh.
What!
(delighted laughter)
Oh my god, I'm like a pony!
- [David] It's like a hint of silver.
- [Luis] Yeah.
- [David] With some lilac in it.
- I'm excited!
I think it matches my personality.
- Oh!
Hoo!
Holy moly!
- [David] You look crazy, yo!
- [Yoshi] This is phenomenal hair.
- I honestly think that you look like
the best version of yourself.
- Ooh!
- [Yoshi] Yo, girls that color your hair,
mad respect, because
beauty is seriously pain.
- [Luis] Before, I was
just like a regular guy,
but now, it was like bam,
(snaps fingers) on your face!
- [Richardson] If you wanna
change your hair color, do it,
just do it, it's about time
we changed the standards.
- [Voiceover] I would consider
coloring my hair again.
- [Edward] I look forward
to moving forward in my life
with this new look.